tu avec nous j'accueille bien demain
c'est tout le monde presque tout le
monde
rolland courbis ex entraîneur de l'om
oui je serai remplacé par marchand est
vrai que ce n'était pas la priver james
et que marchand ne sais pas voilà vous
connaissez quand même michel oui bien
sûr philippe bouvard aussi oui richard
cocciante
voilà valérie lemercier anne roumanoff
alors vous arrivez en fait seulement
maintenant parce que vous arrivez du
théâtre dejazet qui est bourrée tous les
soirs c'est incroyable moi j'y suis
allée l'autre salle dit les gens c'est
fou ces fous furieux
c'est peut être même gênant pour vous
non non pas encore c'est aussi un gars
de gagnerez irait il me parle s'ils
connaissent les sketches il vous parle
ça s'appelle une vie normale j'étais un
petit peu une vie normale mise en scène
par isabelle des gens qui font ça parce
que ça c'est un truc qui se fait dans
cette émission c'est à dire que nous ici
quand on fait non nous ici quand on fait
de la pub
quand on fait de la pub on dit formant
aux autres émissions ou à ici quand on
fait de la pub on a donc une vie normale
de jazz les succès ça fait combien de
temps que c'est depuis début janvier
ouais je vous dis les six mois après ce
oui presque et l'on vous étiez
poursuiteur pas poursuivre votre
programme télé spectateurs c'est
quelqu'un qui a une poursuite qui suit
avec une lumière les gens en 93 c'est
vrai oui c'est vrai ça doit faire avec
elie kakou
oui c'est un drôle d'effet dans un
théâtre on a été éclairagiste dix ans de
revenir et d'avoir ce succès là tous les
soirs non ouais c'est assez marrant
parce que d'abord je n'avais pas prévu
du tout de jouer un jour dans ce théâtre
là je voulais faire ce métier là et puis
je suivais je poursuivais die kacou tous
les soirs dans son spectacle
voilà l'histoire et jolie histoire est
assez jolie oui alors le principe du
spectacle c'est quoi si vous avez un
stock de personnages en fait qu'ils sont
vos personnages un peu comme un écrivain
qui écrirait plusieurs bouquins et
vouloir leur donner des rôles vous leur
donnez des dialogues c'est ça non ouais
c'est ça c'est des vrais personnages que
j'essaie de rendre le plus humain
possible
ainsi sont complexes et
on essaye parce que j'ai travailé qu
isabelle nanty qui m'a mis en scène et
donc il ya plusieurs tableaux avec plein
de personnages c'est ce qui m'a mis sur
scène vraiment c'est jouer vraiment des
gens les personnages alors vous dites
que c'est moins puisque c'est un peu moi
pour moi du coup ce coach éric décalage
j'ai dû dire que c'était moins
autobiographique que le premier
spectacle que je parlais vraiment de
l'identité du voyage du décalage
culturel et là je parle d'autre chose
parce que moi aussi j'ai bougé j'ai
évolué donc je sais pas si j'ai prononcé
le mot couscous youri sonore c'est moi
d'accord pour me regarder un petit bout